Europa sigue intentando protegerse del
covi 19 este jueves Alemania se sumó a
la lista de países del bloque europeo
como Austria Bélgica Suecia que si
jirates covid negativo a Los viajeros
procedentes de China
la entrada sólo se permite con una
prueba negativa Esa es la base y también
investigaremos sistemáticamente las
variantes en los aeropuertos mediante
muestras aleatorias y llevaremos a cabo
un control sistemático de las aguas
residuales para que podamos evitar el
peligro aquí
a partir del jueves Estados Unidos
también impondrá restricciones de
entradas similares a los pasajeros que
provengan del gigante asiático sin
embargo los datos muestran que la Sub
variante ve a cinco que actualmente
prevalece en China es la cepa dominante
en el país norteamericano la
Organización Mundial de la Salud señaló
que no se ha observado ninguna nueva
variante de importancia conocida Y ante
las acciones tomadas por los gobiernos
europeos y el estadounidense para evitar
el rebrote masivo en sus territorios
Beijing hace hincapié no tomar medidas
discriminatorias hacemos un llamamiento
a todas las partes para que adopten
medidas de respuesta basadas en la
ciencia y proporcionadas que no apuntan
a ningún país en concreto eviten
comentarios y acciones que politicen la
epidemia salvaguarden conjuntamente en
el intercambio normal entre personas y
trabajen juntos por una pronta Victoria
sobre la pandemia las autoridades chinas
también pidieron a sus habitantes que
cumplan los requisitos exigidos por
terceros para viajar mientras la Unión
Europea acuerda un enfoque de precaución
comunitario puesto que a partir del 8 de
enero el covid dejará de ser una
enfermedad de categoría a la de más alto
riesgo en China